hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at [ __ ]
boys it's time for the drink again and
this time I spent so long farming and
getting ready and getting you know
making sure my files weren't deleted
from last one then I kind of sobered up
a bit so what I'm gonna do is I'm going
to take a double shot but since I don't
have a double shot glass I'm just going
to take two shots so Cheers
Oh God
cheers once more unto the breach my
friends I'm not pretty I'm not stalling
at all stalling for the burden to go
down from the cinnamon and bra oh it
burns so good Oh remember everybody this
serious is not for children and I am an
adult and a professional and know what I
can handle don't copy this at home oh
good god oh man that's burns my
epiglottis is burning it wants to go
down my windpipe oh that's warm ah the
reason I chose fireball is because it
was between that and tequila and I did
not want to drink tequila shots all day
long this I can actually tolerate okay
so the reason I started now is something
that you're gonna see because I saw
something that weirded me out and I
don't know why is here oh so I leveled
up quite a [ __ ] and also I quite a bit
and also I found the last balloon boy
shop he's in the down right corridor I
didn't see that and there's a bunch of
Omega things also I got Barney his
kingly guitar I think what happens is
the the the certain types of hats have a
very rare chance of dropping us and one
of these characters special oh whatever
you know what this is the weird thing
who the [ __ ] is on the stage what is
that a dog that doesn't make any sense
for you
[Music]
oh hey hi toy Freddy how's it goin
how tough are ya Jeremy how tough are
you I'm not gonna take any chances with
this [ __ ] I'm gonna I'm gonna give
him what for I'm gonna show them what
whoo I'm gonna do what to him doo doo
doo doo
bunny hop sure why not
blam blam blam blam oh [ __ ] oh god he's
still standing Jesus this guy's not
gonna go down very easily is he well
good thing I'm gonna use all of my
skills to get this guy dead
hopefully beats a PLAs on yourself
because you can't do anything else
chica bunnyhop away it takes so little
for the bunny hop that's actually
adorable then doesn't to all that much
or it doesn't take all that much to do a
lot okay to a friend you pass it to
yourself tiga don't act like you're all
high and mighty oh boy yes ain't gonna
go real good I don't have enough for
that damn it geez why is this happening
what does this happen to me okay jeez
you do so much damage this was a mistake
going after this guy this was a big-ass
mistake okay
I don't have I don't have anything that
can heal only chica you kneel so I might
as well use foxy this green chica chica
DS he'll need to revive I don't know
heal or revive I don't really know which
wow whatever I'll revive cuz Freddy's
important for some reason actually I
don't know oh god damn it wouldn't it
mattered anyway because Chico is going
down fall over already
[ __ ] he says oh my god
I don't know if I should stop to try and
heal or what oh well this is a great way
to end this episode art this episode
because it's an utter failure from the
get-go here god damn it oh please miss
Oh poison - that's fantastic finish him
off okay
did it mean Bonnie I met you well
apparently you're not supposed to go
after toy Freddy because he will [ __ ]
you up
he'll [ __ ] you up real good so all I
know is I'm gonna go back to my original
plan which is this try to beat the
goddamn cameras because I'll do that
first but first I need to farm more in
this area to be stronger and be able to
get the stuff that I need to be able to
do what I need to do which is good
because this particular area has a lot
of these triple things man that bunnyhop
can like kill one guy instantaneously
it's awesome yeah you guys do your thing
we're gonna do our thing and then
Bonnie's just going to take care of
kill and Qigong okay yeah all right so
this is gonna be boring for you so all
I'm gonna do is I'm just gonna keep
going what I really wanted to do is I
wanted to take more shots that's why I
started the episode and I also saw toy
bonnie up there who looked like a
freaking dog okay so I think I'm in a
good point then I can beat this goddamn
camera so I'm assuming the other camera
on the other side was probably the final
final boss and I was supposed to go here
first because Freddy kills from the left
one in the first game flashback to like
when I first played this game and it was
all new and it was like no story to be
found and everything was just new and
interesting and is bad now but it's just
like a bunch of nostalgia it's like this
time oh [ __ ] the puppet oh [ __ ] duck
I gotta be Oh kill him kill him kill him
kill him kill him
hit a hard harder harder harder harder
oh that was it god damnit that's just as
much of the bunny hop
I'll be back when I beat him I'm gonna
lose I'm gonna find out what the puppet
does real quick here why I want to know
about it but hey it's gonna happen wait
why am I not reviving bonnie bonnie is
like one of my heart is hitters now
because he's got the [ __ ] ass think
pieces to me I did I look good okay just
survive one goddamn more such that you
can revive the son of a [ __ ] don't get
hit okay you poured it into his ass
that's great I'm not gonna question that
because that's weird
but whatever fine by me I don't know
okay Megan rush down she could do
something I don't know heal yourself
Jesus
you use like [ __ ] bunny hop bunny
goddammit haha oh wow yeah no kidding oh
oh oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
fine I'm assuming I'm gonna die well
that's death cool that didn't do nothing
Oh credit good for almost leapt not
quite Oh why'd he turn orange I don't
know I'm not even gonna try I failed
because I wasn't even thinking oh I mean
you instantly killed Freddie but I don't
know I don't wonder anymore because he's
got to be a complete like everyone in
the kingly weapons and everyone doing
everything to be able to beat this guy I
don't even know if he's possible to be
beaten to be perfectly honest if he can
heal himself like a big bag yes son of a
[ __ ] I was just about to be I beat the
camera and you okay so I gotta go back
to the puppet I gotta be able to be
debuffing I gotta make sure the father
doesn't come after me because that was
scary as hell
oh why is Balloon Boy up on the thing
whoa toy chica what are you doing here
I'm not gonna talk to you screw that
Jesus why are you all here okay dad
screw you god damn it this is so weird
why are they all here do I have to fight
Balloon Boy is that a thing that I would
have to fight and also why why would I
need to do that it's probably all this
probably it's unlocked with levels but I
just want to be able to beat this one so
nice because I don't know why I think
the cameras the thing that moves the
story forward but
I don't know wastin thing but the bunny
hop that's cheap and efficient then old
poison me Conde I'll be right back god
these fights are taking longer and
longer know what the puppet came after
me Jesus yes eat my [ __ ] all over your
face because that's what I did because
I'm Freddy kids apparently that's what
Freddy does when he's having a good time
of a native debauchery but they don't
want to know what I did yes okay so
we're all good we're all good real good
I need to go get the puppet actually
what I need to do before I get the
puppet is I need to get more equipment
because they don't think I have all the
equipment just here in healed my dong
enragement jeweled so I don't have to
these bodies which I thought I was gonna
be able to get more nyet okay fine bye
I'll put them on later but um unless all
the toys are gonna come after me yeah
toy don't do that don't do that I really
don't know what like what more this game
is gonna want for me after I do think
that it you son of a [ __ ] trying to get
to where I need to go for the goddamn
puppet because he's a second thank [ __ ]
so now that I got that camera down the
only thing I the camera that I need to
get is the one on the other side he's
probably just as tough if only a little
bit tougher than this one but I think I
can do it maybe just a little more
farming but I don't know I've been
farming a lot I'm eager to move on to
the next episode every time I farm have
to cut it out for the length of the
episode or whatever it's I'm gonna I'm
gonna farm some more fine you know I'm
gonna talk to you guys while I'm farming
because frankly I have some things to
say I don't know what about but I'm
gonna talk anyway because talking is
pretty much what I do I mean I like I've
said it before but when I went back to
Cincinnati this last time actually I got
to see some friends that I haven't seen
in a long time because my visit still
Ohio I've been you and far between and I
have not been able to do what I wanted
to do which was visit as much as I
wanted to do
and like it's really cool because like I
have such great friends back home that
yeah it doesn't matter how long that
that I've been gone there they're really
happy to see me and like they organised
a little get-together for me to go on a
little party and I was really honored
that they did that and what's more
interesting is that a lot of them are
teachers like a lot of our teachers and
their kids or their students are fans of
mine like a lot of them more and more
these days or fans of mine and so so
weird to go back there like yeah my my
students talk about you all the time and
they asked me you know like am I really
your friend and they go yeah yeah I'm
his friend and it's just like well [ __ ]
it's just the thing that's happening now
because like I know there's a lot a lot
of you guys out there and we just hit 7
million we're already shooting past 7
million but this is like just thinking
about it from that perspective where my
friends are realizing that like holy
crap there's a lot of people that like
this guy on the internet and he just
happens to me my friend like um it's a
weird honor that that's a thing that's
happening but it's still really good to
see my friends again I'm very lucky to
have such a kind circle of friends that
has stuck together since high school and
whatnot I mean there's been drama here
and there and a little falling out in
there obviously it's not perfect I'm
gonna say it's perfect but it's good
like it was good for me I mean despite
the fact that the only reason I was able
to stay home for as long as I did was
the hospital visit it also kind of put
it in perspective to me that you know I
don't need to work myself to death
because you guys have been so loving
while I was in the hospital literally
not able to upload videos and for a few
days they're like I still uploaded a
video every day but it's like a
technicality I uploaded a one-minute
update from the hospital as my video and
so it wasn't technically content so I
don't know what you think about my
ending my streak of never missing a
day's upload but I'd like to think I did
like take a little bit of effort and
willpower to be able to make a video
from the hospital like that but still I
just got to say like it put it into
perspective like the things I do for fun
and the things I
for work are separate like III what I'm
doing right now is what I would consider
really fun and it's a good facet of what
I do as a job and why I'm able to do it
like I'm able to just like take shots of
mysterious non-brand
alcohol and play a game for you guys
like it's like we're all sitting on the
big couch of America and or the world
actually because I have a lot of fans
outside of America I do that's true I do
and just like have fun together like
that's like the most amazing privilege
that I have about this job that I have
on YouTube and and it's all thanks to
you guys in the fact that I'm able to do
it I don't know why I'm expanding so
much about it but just you know it's
just cool to see and it always just nice
to have it put in perspective for me
because you know it's not always that I
get a chance to see it the way that
other people see it like my friends
point of view of how their students are
fans of mine and they indirectly get
exposure to this weird spillover of what
you would call internet fame and and
that's this is a really cool thing
that's a really interesting thing anyway
so that was those of rambling for me to
talk while I was farming I suppose so
and just like I don't know I have a lot
of love for you guys and I have a lot of
love for my friends and someday I'll be
back in Cincinnati I mean not that la is
bad because I've been able to hang out
with some really really cool people and
I've been grateful for that
do I not level up past 20 is this like
the limit I don't level up any past 20
is that so what we're doing here
there was no point for me to grind all
that besides getting kokand for the
stupid douchebag
alright fine whatever that I'm just
gonna go get the last of my equipment
now I'm gonna be good I didn't know that
20 was the limit I guess this game
really but I need to get the rest of
Bonnie's things not that I'd ever use
anything else BRB BRB okay so we're back
in order and I'm fully up in all the
upgrades that I could possibly get
besides like the kingly stuff for the
other guys but that's gonna take a lot
more farming just because it takes a lot
of time to get the luck to be able to
get what you need there so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to beat the
other camera because that's the last
camera that I need to beat and then see
where I go from there because
I don't know if there's like an
alternate ending to the game huge feat
all the toys before you beat the camera
so I need to find out if that's the case
but I know I can beat this camera I know
I can beat it into the ground so BRB as
I do that the puppy come on the back run
god damn it Barney [ __ ] ah tense no no
no no get god damn it oh god damn it
come on the puppet pour the soda it's
funny [ __ ] oh crap Oh No please die
please split all God yes that's what I
wanted brush down rush balls
[Music]
oh boy thank you for just spewing smoke
in my face
Oh missing balls cockiness
what's more the God spreadsheets - ran
[ __ ] in ass
[Music]
[Applause]
John dammit [ __ ] [ __ ] a month gay not
[ __ ] monkey that bad okay so what I
need to do apparently my god what am I
supposed to do I got the max equipment
I've got literally the best of
everything I guess I'm supposed to beat
all these [ __ ]
so toy toy Freddy was first so I guess
I'll try him the [ __ ] bag whatever
whatever whatever whatever okay why you
gotta be such a oh why you're so wimpy
[Music]
[Applause]
it's not going good at all this is like
holy [ __ ]
god damn it what the [ __ ] am I supposed
to do this doesn't make us gods in pill
sense oh [ __ ] what am I supposed to do I
can't do any tits oh I'm trying to think
I'm trying to use my brain I'm supposed
to be doing do I need all the kingly
items on everybody like what do you want
let's try one of the other ones Wow cuz
why not you know yeah I feel a little
sassy maybe chicas gonna be a little bit
easier if you know what I mean no no yes
that's quite an answer no just no
whatever
no okay
at least poisoning I guess I'll use my
skills let's get everyone actually stuff
here let's do things to this I do not
know how about use cards don't know this
is going a little bit better I mean the
game is actually not being totally
unfair to me when I'm playing against
this [ __ ] but hey I know that I can
change at any moment
oh boy I do notice that this game is a
lot less about fuck-boy Inge than it is
about just beating up and if the trucks
if [ __ ] Freddy's if that makes any
sense at all whatever you don't want to
be shut up I know what I'm talking about
shut up I know shut up shut up I think
I'm gonna be able to beat chica because
she is not totally annihilating me like
all the other animatronics were but then
again maybe I'm just wrong in the
annihilation is just about to happen
maybe right about now no oh all right
it's up to you Freddy you gotta get
cheeky back up then rush it rush you're
down to rush her down rush you're down
to bunnyhop rush her down to Buddy how
come on take her out she doesn't do all
that much damage so we might be able to
do good buddy a bit about a move now
come on you son of a [ __ ] oh crap oh
how much shells do you have you friggin
prick damn it yeah crap all the puppets
gonna give me at this point
oh they're gonna see good god damn it
god damn it
[ __ ] doc oh my god I gotta go I gotta go
come on come on
I already take finally [ __ ] not a duck
chicken but [ __ ] god damn 10000 even
though that doesn't matter because I'm
already level up learned flighty combo
combo it's good combo maybe the combos
gonna be doing good
Oh flighty combo oh I learned chicas
ultimate move that means chicas gonna be
able to do so good in the future or not
because [ __ ] I don't know whatever it
just hope that it's gonna help me in the
end and not in the end where you shove
it up soda up people's bums okay
lamb-lamb
okay so get to the goddamn puppet right
about goddamn now okay okay alright
god damn holy hell in a handbasket this
has been brutal you haven't even seen
all that I've been to hink with all the
farming crap
holy [ __ ] on a cracker
okay so anyway I think I don't know it's
hard to tell I look at the waveform on
the audio file that I've been doing late
the hypotenuse so how many gaps are in
there and how much total time it is I
don't know it's probably 24 minutes I
have no idea but are you a bat in this
episode here thank you everybody so much
for watching hope you're enjoying this
as much as I am because I'm actually
making progress
oh no and objective is but I'm doing
something but either way thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always
[Music]
okay
night
[Music]